as policymakers debate when and how to
reopen the state economies public health
officials continue to warn about the
danger of moving too fast joining us now
from Baltimore dr. tom ingoldsby
director of the center for health
security at Johns Hopkins University dr.
good to be with you again morning Chris
where are we with the virus have we
reached the peak are we on the down
slope of the virus and now that we see
the number of deaths over 53,000 almost
54,000 this morning can you give us a
sense of the range of how many deaths we
may see from this virus overall
depending on how careful we are in the
Rio and the reopening yes I would say
that we are for lack of better words
maybe near the end of the beginning of
this pandemic in this country we have
reached a plateau nationally at this
point I mean trends can change over time
but at this point we have a plateau in
new cases per day unfortunately it's a
very high plateau we still are seeing
about 30,000 new cases of kovat 19 every
day in the United States and still are
seeing something on the order of 2,000
deaths per day so we are not through out
of the woods by any means in terms of
this pandemic but at least we've reached
a kind of a stable number of new
infections and the number of people who
are dying from this illness if you and
when we're talking about mom let me just
say at one point we were talking about
models 1 million people then it was a
hundred thousand people then it was 60
now we're already up to 53,000 so give
me a sense of the number I understand
these are these are predictions but the
number of fatalities we might see from
this so I think modelers are pretty
reluctant to model way beyond a month or
two out from now because of so many
variables if we change our social
distancing policies and depending on how
well states get prepared
for the easing into the reopening that
could change outcomes quite a bit but
the leading models at the moment predict
anywhere from fifty eight thousand
deaths to a hundred and ten thousand
deaths in the next month in the United
States I think no one's really modeling
beyond that and really it's going to
depend on many things that are difficult
to wrap up into a single number alright
let me ask you one more question
trying to foresee the future vice
president pence gave a timeline this
week for when we're going to come out of
this here he is if you look at the
trends today that I think by Memorial
Day weekend we will largely have this
coronavirus epidemic behind us Memorial
Day weekend doctor is that realistic
well at this point if you go
state-by-state you see that about half
of the country in half of the country
the numbers are still rising day to day
about another third of the country there
seems to be a leveling off and only a
minority of in a minority of the country
the numbers are actually coming down day
by day and so I I don't think it's
likely that we will be at that position
by Memorial Day but even more
importantly wherever we are in the
epidemic this virus is going to be with
us until we have a vaccine so as we ease
up on social distancing measures and
economies begin to very carefully reopen
we are at risk of recurrence or Reese
pikes in the illness in the epidemic so
I think everyone needs to be aware that
even as we're beginning to open up again
there is a a clear chance of a rise in
cases in states that are doing that
let's talk about that because a number
of states as you know are beginning to
reopen spas salons gyms even restaurants
is that safe for people you know you
talk about a spa where people are giving
massage as a
a salon where people are filing people's
nails are cutting their hair is that
safe for people to be that close at this
point if there were masks and gloves I
don't think it's going to be possible
for anyone to say something is safe you
know completely safe at this point
because the virus is very transmissible
between people and because some people
don't have symptoms at least either in
the beginning of the illness or maybe
even at all during their illness but we
can say some things are safer than
others and businesses that have small
numbers of people are probably safer
than businesses that have very large
numbers of people and the closeness of
the interaction that also is a factor so
if people are going to be closely
interacting they should be using
personal protective equipment if that's
available in their state and outdoors
will be safer than indoors so there is a
range of different there are gonna be a
range of different risks that businesses
face and it's important for all
businesses now to be trying to
understand the risks and making plans
for how to diminish the risks as best
they can within their own business their
own operations look let me ask you a
quick question would you feel safe at
this point getting a haircut
getting a massage if you and the person
doing it we're both wearing gloves and
masks I think at this point in most
places in the country with the rate of
illness as it is I don't think so there
may be some places where community
community transmission is so low and
testing is so good that we have
confidence that the risk is low but I'd
say I would be cautious about doing that
at this point you talked about testing I
know one of the problems you have with
the White House guidelines is that you
think they failed to address the issues
of testing and contact tracing here is
President Trump on that this week we're
doing very well in testing we've tested
far more than anybody
anywhere in the world that were just not
there no I don't agree with them on that
no I think we're doing a great job in
testing we're averaging averaging about
a hundred and fifty thousand tests a day
isn't that enough no it's not enough and
the reason why is because we're not
testing a lot of the mild and moderate
illness that isn't people who aren't
sick enough to be in the hospital and so
all those people are not getting counted
and they aren't necessarily having their
contacts traced or told to isolate in
their own homes so we're missing a lot
of the illness in the country until we
get that under control we're gonna
continue to have lines of transmission
that we can see and beyond that many
businesses are now really beginning to
think about how that Diagnostics might
factor into their reopening plans and we
just don't have diagnostic testing
available on large scale for businesses
we're still focused on diagnosing the
sickest people those in nursing homes
healthcare workers which is completely
appropriate but they're a small fraction
of the number of people that we're gonna
need to test to really find all the
illness and to get the economy moving in
the right direction again I want to
squeeze two more questions in here in
the time we have left doctor I want to
ask you about another white house
guideline and that is a steady decline
in the number of new cases over the
course of two weeks I want to put some
stats on this Green Oklahoma is coming
down from its peak but had a 26%
increase in new cases in the last week
and it went over the course of the last
week from the numbers jump from a low of
29 new cases last Sunday to over a
hundred new cases justice passed
Thursday and Friday should a state with
those kinds of numbers be reopening now
again I would be very cautious about
doing that I think we've seen there's an
example in the papers this morning about
a state in Japan that reopened quickly
in March after
few weeks of numb lowish numbers and
three weeks later rebounded to the point
where they have to now close their
economy down again so I think it's going
to be important to really go slowly for
those states who do reopen I think it
should be done very carefully with a lot
of monitoring of both hospitalization
rate ICU rate death rates so at this
point only about five states in the
country to my count have had two weeks
of decline so only about two weeks in
the two states or five states rather in
the country have met the gating criteria
laid out by the White House I got about
a minute left for one final question as
you know President Trump yeah has come
under fire over the last week or so
first for advocating the use of
hydroxychloroquine and then later this
week this week for talking about the
possibility speculating about the
possibility of injecting disinfectant
here he is on that I see the
disinfectant we're nuts about in a
minute one minute
and is there way we can do something
like that by injection inside or almost
a cleaning I know you want to stay away
from politics and I think it's clear
that that any kind of ingestion of a
disinfectant is dangerous but but two
quick questions one where are you at
this point about the use of
hydroxychloroquine and two how do we
sort through all of the conflicting
advice that we get well into your first
question I think the there needs to be
more study of hydroxychloroquine two
studies that have come out so far have
suggested it is possibly more harmful
than helpful and protect possibly
dangerous so I don't think anyone should
be taking hydroxychloroquine unless they
are in a randomized controlled trial
that's being carefully studied and the
second point is that I think the the
most important thing now in terms of
medicines and vaccines is to follow
where medical leaders and scientific
leaders
guide us they're doing the studies these
studies take time these medicines can
actually hurt people so there is a harm
that could potentially right happen if
people take medicines that aren't
studied so it's important to follow the
scientists dr. Inglesby thank you thanks
for joining us again and giving us your
expert analysis please come back thanks
so much